let me go then to one of the other three
principles of freedom because one of the
ways to keep government accountable is
the freedom of the press
so there's a the internet and on the
internet there's social networks and one
of them is called Twitter I think you
have an account there people should
follow you and uh you know recently
people have been throwing around
recently for a while the words of
freedom of speech uh just out of
curiosity uh for tangent upon a tangent
uh what do you think of freedom of
speech as it is today and as it was at
that time during the Civil War after the
Civil War and throughout the history of
of America so freedom of speech has
always been one of the core tenets of
American democracy and I'm near
absolutist on it uh because I I think
that people should have the right to
speak uh what what makes our democracy
function is that there is always room
for quite frankly people like you and me
who uh like to disagree and have reasons
to disagree so I am against almost all
forms of censorship the only time I
believe in censorship is if somehow an
individual or newspaper has stolen the
Ukrainian plans for their next military
movements in the next week you should
not be able to publish that right now
maybe after they act but criticism
opinion interpretation should be wide
open now that doesn't mean though that
um you have the right to come to my
classroom and start shouting and saying
whatever you want yeah you have the
right on the street corner to do that
but my classroom is a classroom for my
students with a particular purpose sorry
about that from last week I'll never do
it again
I'm really sorry it's okay it never
happened I get drunk so the people who
don't know your your professor UT Austin
is just it's nearby so sometimes I I get
a little drunk and wander in there I'm
not the only one was that you I didn't
even know it was you okay
um so the point is that free speech is
not licensed to invade someone else's
space and and I also believe in private
Enterprise so I think that um
you know if if if I owned a social media
Network I don't
it would be up to me to decide
who gets to speak on that Network and
who doesn't and then people could decide
not to use it if they don't want to use
it but there's uh so yes that's one of
the founding principles so oftentimes
when you talk about censorship that's
government uh censorship so social media
if you run a social media company you
should be able to decide from a
technical perspective of what freedom of
speech means but there's some deeper
ethical philosophical
a sense of
um how do you create a world where
every voice is heard of the People by
the people for the people that's not a
that's a complicated technical problem
when you have a Public Square how do you
have a productive conversation where
critics aren't silenced but the same
time Whoever has the bigger megaphone is
not going to crowd out everybody else so
I think it's very important to uh create
rules of the game that'll give everyone
a chance to get started and that
um allow for guideposts to be created
from the will of the community which is
to say that we as a community can say We
Can't Stop people from speaking but we
as a community can say that in certain
forms we're going to create certain
rules
for who gets to speak and who doesn't
under what terms but they can still have
somewhere else to go so I'm I believe in
Opening space for everyone but creating
certain spaces within those spaces that
are designed for certain purposes that's
what a school does so I will not bring
someone to speak to my students who is
unqualified it's not a political
judgment the rules at a university are
where an educational institution you
need to have the educational credentials
to come speak about artificial
intelligence I'm not going to bring some
bum off the street to do that right we
have certain rules but that bomb on the
street can still in his own space or her
own space can still say what he or she
wants to say about artificial
intelligence this is how newspapers work
when I write for the New York Times They
have an editorial team the editorial
team makes certain decisions they check
facts uh and there's certain points of
view they don't allow anti-submitted
comments
right you're not going to be able to
publish an anti-semitic screed whether
you think it's true or not true in the
New York Times but that doesn't prevent
you from finding somewhere else so we
allow entities to create certain rules
of the game we trans we make transparent
what those rules are and then we as
Citizens know where to go to get our
information what's what's been a problem
the last few decades I think is it
hasn't been clear what the rules are in
different places and what are the
legitimate places to get information and
what are not yeah the transparency seems
to be very critical there even from the
New York Times I think there's a lot of
skepticism about which way the editorial
processes lean I mean there's a public
perception that it's especially for
opinions it's going to be very
left-leaning in the New York Times and
without transparency
about what the process is like about the
people involved you all you do like
conspiracy theories and and the general
public opinion about that is going to go
go wild
and uh I think that's okay for the New
York Times people can in a collective
way figure stuff out like they could say
okay New York Times uh 73 of the time is
gonna lean left in their head they have
like a loose estimation or whatever uh
but for a platform like Twitter it seems
like they're it's more complicated now
of course there should be rules of the
game but I think there's uh
maybe I want to say a responsibility to
also create incentives for people to do
High effort empathetic debate
versus throwing poop at each other yeah
I think those are two slightly different
things so I agree
I think that my view is that the failure
of Facebook and Twitter and others in in
recent years has been that they have
been completely untransparent about
their rules so what I would think would
make would Advance us
is if they had a set of rules that were
clear that were consistently followed
and we understood what they were that
would also tell us as consumers
how much what the biases are how to
understand what's going on it seems like
I might say that since Elon Musk is
taken over Twitter it's been arbitrary
and who's thrown off and who's not
thrown off who's and that's that's a
real problem arbitrariness is in some
ways the opposite of democracy but
there's also a hidden arbitrariness
in uh
interpretation of the rules so for
example
what comment incites violence
that's really really difficult to figure
out to me like there's a gray area
obviously there's very clear versions of
that but if I know anything about people
that try to incite violence they're
usually not coming out and clearly
saying it they're usually kind of dog
whistling it and same with racism and
anti-Semitism all of that it's usually
dog whistles so like and they usually
I have fun playing with the rules
playing around the rules so it's a it's
a gray area same with uh June covid
misinformation what's misinformation
right I agree and some of these are
age-old problems our legal system common
law has been struggling with what is
incitement to violence since the first
Supreme Court decisions in the 18th
century right so so you're absolutely
right but I will say this there are
certain things that are clearly
incitement to violence I'll give you
very clear examples uh I'll just make it
personal right my wife is an elected
official here in Austin there have been
people who have put things up on Twitter
calling for her to be hanged or calling
for her to be attacked that's incitement
of violence when you specifically call
for violence against someone I agree
there's a lot of other stuff where it's
a gray area but we could start
if we're applying these rules
yes by getting that material off of
these sites so some of that is a problem
of scale too but the gray area is still
a forever problem that we may never be
able to solve and maybe the tension
within the gray area is the very process
of democracy but saying like we need to
take our country back
is that excitement of violence I don't
think that I think we need to take our
country back just that no
but then you know because I might say
that I might say we need to take I say
that all the time I go again I walk
around drunk just screaming at everybody
I know you wanted it wants to take you
back exactly I was very confused and my
messaging needs to work but let's let's
go to the January 6th example right to
say hang Mike Pence that's inside me the
violence yeah to say go get Nancy
that's incitement to violence yeah yeah
it's very clear again I don't think
that's the big problem the big problem
is the gray area but yet
uh and the other problem is just how to
get how to technically find the large
scale of comments and posts and so on
that are doing this kind of clearance I
understand I mean don't ask me those
questions well I have to say some of
that is motivation some of that is
vision and some of that is execution so
for example just to go out briefly on a
dark topic
um something I've recently became aware
of is you know
Facebook and Twitter and so on people
post uh violence on there like little
like videos of violence child porn
um some of the darkest things in this
world and to find them at scale is is a
difficult problem
and to act in it aggressively is a
difficult problem but uh that
I think
part of this motivation like saying this
is a big problem we need to take this on
we need to uh find all the darkest
aspects of human nature that rise and
appear on our platform and remove them
so that we can create a place for like
for Humanity to flourish through the
process of conversation but it's just
hard it's just really hard when you look
at like millions of posts trillions of
interactions it's wild what's like the
amount of data but where we are now with
with social media seemed wild and
impossible five years ago right yes I I
actually what frustrates me is I think
they're people who have politicized this
issue in unnecessary ways everyone
regardless of their politics should
support what you just said investing our
money
maybe grants from the federal government
in AI skilled people like you figuring
out ways to get violent videos yeah off
of there that that shouldn't be
political
well some of that also requires being
transparent from a social media company
perspective and transparent in a way
that really resists uh being political
to be able to be transparent about your
fight against these
uh evils while still not succumbing to
the sort of the political narratives of
it oh that's tricky but you have to do
that kind of and and walk calmly through
the fire because that's that's what
Twitter feels like if you're being
political is it it's like a firing squad
from every side you know as a leader you
have to kind of walk calmly right and
that is where we need a new generation
of people who will have diverse politics
but will stand up against that right I
mean that's the lesson from after the
Civil War is where progress is made the
war doesn't solve problems of hate where
progress is made is where you have local
leaders and others who stand up and say
we can differ but we're not going we're
going to stop calling people from
certain backgrounds monkeys which was a
common thing to do at that time Jews are
still called monkeys in certain places
right people have to stand up while
still maintaining their political
differences